fast and furious 9 is no longer fast
approaching theatres and there's a
chance fans will be furious about it you
think this is a joke huh as confirmed by
Variety Universal Pictures has to lay
the 9th fast film by almost a year amid
concerns over the worldwide coronavirus
outbreak it's the kind of thing that can
make you want to lean back crack open a
cold one and wait for it also blow over
the studio's decision arose after
consideration about the consequences
kovat 19 a new strain of the corona
virus family of viruses are originated
in Wuhan China at the end of 2019 has
already had on the global economy and
what the continual spread of the disease
will do to the film industry at large
one thing I can guarantee you done no
one's ready for this copán 19 is as of
the making of this video most prominent
in China South Korea and Italy countries
that have taken serious precautions to
keep their citizens safe such preventive
measures include canceling public
gatherings issuing quarantine orders and
of course shutting down movie theaters
many outlets are reporting that the
United States may follow the example of
these overseas territories with regard
to theater closures noted bloodsport fan
President Trump even evoke the action
franchise because inadvertently while
hosting the Irish Prime Minister on
March 12th when you think of what
happened here
fast and furious 9 was scheduled to open
in theaters on May 22nd 2020 now it will
arrive on cinema screens on April 2nd
2021 international release dates are
apparently being ironed out but the
intention is to launch the 9th fast film
worldwide in April of next year the cast
and crew of f 9 released a statement on
twitter addressing the delay which read
in part we feel all the love and the
anticipation you have for the next
chapter in our saga that's why it's
especially tough to let you know that we
have to move the release date of the
film it's become clear that it won't be
possible for all of our fans around the
world to see the film this may well we
know there is disappointment and having
to wait a little while longer
this move is made with the safety of
everyone as our foremost consideration
moving will allow our global family to
experience our new chapter together
we'll see you next spring though is
completely understandable why Universal
Pictures has delayed f9 or feels
particularly disappointing about this
development is up Vin Diesel who Lisa
chose as a racing aficionado Dom Toretto
recently assured fans at the film's
release date wouldn't be changed
diesel promise f9 was sticking to its
planned made 20-second release date in
an interview published March 7th a
diesel said I won't fall tell you what
in the world for saying you guys are
stupid for releasing this movie right
now but we need movies now more than
ever we're already in a very interesting
time where cinema and a cinematic
experience is so threatened so yes put
it on record we're going to show up
what's a double bummer about this
situation is that this isn't the first
time F 9 has suffered a lengthy delay
the film was slated to hit theaters on
April 19th 2019
however when Universal prioritize a fast
and furious spin our pops and Shore
starring Dwayne Johnson and Jason
Statham over the main franchise entry f9
was pushed to April 10th 2020 before
later settling into its may 22nd 2020
slots
what's interesting about f9 being pushed
back from almost an entire year from not
its first or second but third
established release date is that its new
one is the exact date Universal
previously intended to release Fast and
Furious 10 installment meant to mark the
end of the core film franchise with F 9
now occupying that spots what does it
mean for fast 10 if we do this we risk
everything a simple and sad answer is
that the film will undoubtedly be
delayed as well and probably
substantially at that production on the
film has of course not started yet and
it isn't as if it can begin in the
middle of a global health crisis the
best-case scenario is that filming on
that flake will probably begin sometime
next year which means that according for
the time it takes to complete a movie in
post-production the 10th Fast & Furious
film will most likely receive a spraying
the 2022 release date f9 getting here
with a delay of this caliber is a bummer
all around but better safe than sorry
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite action franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]